season where I carry once the body
wouldn't you use it as sort of like
inspired smart new music tell me about
that yeah so growing up going to school
in the morning I would just put on my I
carry CV Shania Twain Gwen Stefani like
all the greatest at the time when I was
young and I even now I mean Mariah Carey
was the best singer of a decade she's
just incredible vocalist and in a way
she taught me how to sing and cuz I
would just sit in my basement and try
and hit all those high notes like every
night I'm just practicing over and over
again so definitely them and now sweepit
psychos it feels really surreal because
I've been at this for so long and and in
a way I don't get nervous anymore it's
more of it just it feels like a relief
and like you know an overwhelming
feeling but like a relief as well
because I've been doing it for so long
and I'm really excited about if it's
like oh I read it with a few friends of
mine and we feel like we all have
dualities to us and the song is really
just about being misunderstood and this
girl feels like she's out of her mind
she's in this relationship where she's
so passionate but instead she's being
called psycho and yeah we're not psycho
at all we are strong independent females
and that's just how it is yeah it's
crazy I mean you can never predict these
things we just wanted to put it out cuz
we thought it was so much fun and we
wanted to bring more pop back and yeah
you can't you can't predict these things
I we're still overwhelmed and excited
and shocked at what it's doing so what
are your parents first time they saw
the song what did they have a reactor
they're carting knives from the house
like what did they know they were they
they're just happy they're like they're
excited that I get to write my own music
video treatments now I'm really
creatively involved in everything so
they're definitely they're definitely
excited about what's to come you know I
love my debut album yeah is it similar
to sweet but psycho the same sort of
sound yeah it's a it's a lot of pop pop
anthems I can say that right now but
it's definitely an autobiography of me
is there a lot of success in psycho um I
feel like the pressure isn't there for
me because I've had pressure growing up
for so long that it kind of just fell
off I'm just like a few years ago it's I
don't look at anything like pressure
anymore I just really want to be able to
support my family and be happy and just
provide for people I love and make music
and do what I love as well so yeah so
where do you see yourself in like 5 10
years 5 10 years from now hopefully
performing still and making more music
and making more albums
don't forget who you are I feel like my
family really humbled me and grounded me
since the beginning so just that yeah
it's up to me spoke about off camera was
you know a lot of people think like you
just Hatcher you have this whole night
of success like and we know that's not
true
like what would you say how would you
inspire somebody just sort of follow
it's definitely not like that I mean
it's taken over ten years to get where I
am right now
and it's every journey is different I'm
not saying this should you you know
takes ten years to get to where I'm at
but my journey was that and I I feel
like I had so many different times where
it might have could have would have
should have ever happened and it didn't
because I don't think it was meant to be
then and I think it's meant to be now
and I Know Who I am and I know what I
want to give out and I know that I have
this message that I want to share with
the world and that is to be yourself and
just love yourself be that best outcast
you can be other times or in those ten
years what you said you know you wanted
to give up or just I think I never had
another dream
to be honest this was the only dream I
had since I was seven years old and I
feel like I've been manifesting it for
over 15 years actually because that's
all I ever wanted and from the moment I
like stepped on my first stage and
saying so yeah this is this was and will
always be my only dream and just last
question what happens like when you go
on stage what does that make you
it's crazy I feel like I like I get
wings onstage like I can fly I can
teleport I can do anything on stage it
feels like I'm meant to be there
I love it I love the feeling of being on
stage